monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre les
promesses du candidat hollande en 2012
ont été nombreuses sur bien des sujets
elles sont restées sans effet parlons
par exemple du chômage des jeunes
un jeune français sur quatre est
aujourd'hui sans emploi
la promesse d'atteindre 500 milles
apprentis en 2017 est loin d'être
atteinte
pourtant si l'on regarde chez nos
voisins allemands avec 55 % des enfants
d'une classe d'âge qui vont en
apprentissage
ils ont un taux de chômage des jeunes
parmi les plus faibles de l'union
européenne de seulement 8% chez nous
l'alternance stagne alors que c'est elle
qui garantit l'employabilité et cela du
secondaire jusqu'à l'enseignement
supérieur quelle que soit la filière
suivie depuis 2012 votre majorité a
dépensé des milliards d'euros pour des
emplois aidés dont l'efficacité est loin
d'être prouvé que dire des aides aux
entreprises comme le cic eux qui ont
aussi coûté très cher et qui se révèle
aujourd'hui inefficace sur le
développement de l'emploi et même de
l'investissement elles n'ont pas aidé
les entreprises à devenir compétitive ni
à développer les qualifications pourtant
dans le monde qui se dessine la
principale matière première ce sont bien
les qualifications les compétences et la
formation
contrairement à vous nous pensons de ce
côté de l'hémicycle que les jeunes
n'attendent pas un revenu mais avant
tout un travail
il ne demande pas à être assistés mais à
être reconnu professionnellement
alors ma question est simple pourquoi
n'avez vous pas fait de l'apprentissage
une voie d'excellence
pourquoi n'avez vous pas fait de ce
chantier une priorité pour combattre le
chômage des jeunes
merci merci madame la parole et comme
adam clotilde valter secrétaire d'état
chargé de la formation professionnelle
et de l'apprentissage
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
contrairement à ce que vous
venez de dire depuis 2012
l'apprentissage est une des priorités de
ce gouvernement
et je vais vous le démontrer et nous
n'avons effectivement pas la même
conception mesdames et messieurs de
l'opposition pour nous l'apprentissage
est une voie d'excellence pour tous les
jeunes et pour toutes les formations
ça n'est pas comme le propose votre
candidat une voie de relégation et je
vais vous montrer à quel point ce
gouvernement depuis 2000 d'où s'est
attaché à promouvoir cette voie
professionnelle moderne qui s'adresse à
toutes les jeunes et pour toutes les
formations depuis 2012 en effet nous
offre nous avons engagé un certain
nombre d'actions dont une très
importante qui a été engagé par ma
collègue annick girardin qui et qui
consiste à promouvoir l'apprentissage au
sein de la fonction publique comme je
les dis pour tous les jeunes et pour
toutes les formations avec les 10000
emblée 10000 postes d'apprentis créé
dans la fonction publique qui seront
bien atteint en 2010 est au delà ce
gouvernement a également mis en place
une série de dispositifs qui permet
d'abord l'égalité de droit avec les des
étudiants à l'initiative de la ministre
de l'éducation nationale l'égalité des
droits sociaux avec les salariés la
rénovation de notre outil de formation
avec plus de 450 millions d'euros via le
pays a qui ont permis la rénover 100000
plus de cent mille places de formation
de la même façon 280 millions de
ressources supplémentaires ont été
attribués grâce à la taxe
d'apprentissage
nous avons aussi ouvert et diversifié
les formations grâce à l'ouverture des
titres du ministère du travail à la à
l'apprentissage je pense que c'est
agathe c'était l'ensemble de ces
éléments je vais pas pouvoir aller
jusqu'au bout ont permis d'avoir une
augmentation d'avoir une
augmentation dans la mesure où on a
droit à la parole et hommes